foreign
[Music]
season three Nostalgia where you'll have
some new characters but they're kind of
background and like you said you try and
push them forwards over time but you've
got to be really careful that because if
you start pushing old characters out we
won't like it I think that's the safest
effect though or you have to have almost
no new characters and maybe just a
couple of cameos because you don't want
the old characters to overshadow what
you're trying to do which is why with
SGA they brought through Rodney we love
that
but he didn't overshadow the rest of the
what they were trying to do sort of
thing so you've got to go one of those
two ways you can't try and go half and
half or it just won't work at the moment
it looks like they want to bring back
Sam and Daniel Michael Shanks and Amanda
Tapping I keep hearing Rick said I'm all
for it as long as it's connected
but yeah you know the movie all day do
an issue one movie people go
crazy well uh
we would go crazy but the theater thing
doesn't work it's no matter how great it
is it if you do the mini series even
like you said a three hour movie on TV
fine
because you know no matter what they do
with O'Neill as long as they don't do
the cliche we gotta kill them because
now you're done I the audience won't
stand for that you can have them still
be a general there's no idea kill him I
think kill him no no because now you
just you just stomped on the crotch of
everybody that loves Stargate you you
kill him in him going out to Hero
who cares he's still gone he would still
be good it's he's the heart he's 85
years old or 88 years old he's the heart
of the show so now we're getting into
the writing stuff that's different
what if Richard Dean Anderson says I
will come back for the movie but that's
it that's all I'm doing and I want to go
out on a bang got it you know retire him
I don't care no you don't kill people
the moment the moment you kill people
you limit your story you and you tick
off your audience
you know you always you as a writer you
always want to leave a window okay let's
say Richard Dean Anderson says which I
know he doesn't but let's just play the
scenario of he goes I don't want to come
back
he does but let's play that scenario out
yeah
you have to discuss him
and he's retired him and Sam
are happy Sam's there she can let you
know yeah Sam's or you know Jack's home
he's building a deck or whatever and
that way you always have the window
for a cameo down the road during season
nine and ten
okay here's my personal view on this
when Rick stepped away to be with his
daughter I love and respect him and he's
my idol for that yeah I get that but
they always had the opportunity to have
him come back
season 10 he goes hey guys
send him I can come back
I'm free now if you need me because he's
so humble he's not going to demand
anything he goes I'm free if you need me
and
most of the time he was wasted with a
wave at the door kind of you know the
200th episode they could have done more
with that anyway
well there you go so the third movie was
supposed to base around him he was
supposed to be right which okay you can
use those elements to do this new
whatever new series whatever
um but my point is you don't close the
door on opportunity no I say kill him
well that's that's bad I think as a
writer and if you want to have an impact
there's a couple of things you can do
and killing a big star it I'm I'm only
talking about if Richard Dean Anderson
says I will do the movie but that's it
if he's if he says I'll do the movie and
yeah I might do a few cameos here and
there I'd be like brilliant
happy days we've got Anil but if he was
to say look I want to do I'll do the
movie and you're gonna pay me a nice big
paycheck but I don't that that'll do me
though I don't want to do any more
kill him
it would have an emotional impact it
would have a story impact and he ain't
coming back anyway yeah it would he
because I know actors who've changed
their mind and also as an audience you
don't want your Heroes to be done
get him to ascend
sure
he can come back that's my point if you
kill him dead you've ticked off the
audience you've limited your future
possibilities the whole reason for my
audio series is to continue the
adventure you know what I mean so if we
kill him doing something
that's that's right I don't think it's
necessarily it's how you do it obviously
I don't think you have to tick off the
audience I think a lot of the audience
would go nuts
foreign
[Music]